this government our customs is worse
than the Abadi government last year
virtually every a list political figure
in the world descended on South Africa
for the public memorial of nelson
mandela mandela achieved an
extraordinary amount during his turn on
earth there were plenty of epic
storylines and moral lessons to be drawn
from his life and yet this was the news
item that made worldwide headlines South
African sign language interpreter
accused of gesturing gibberish during
the Nelson Mandela memorial and told The
Associated Press he saw angels coming
into the stadium that he had violence in
his past we tried to contact the company
we couldn't reach anyone
the owners seem to have vanished the
translator Fiasco is not an isolated
incident
it is the inevitable outgrowth of a deep
rot at the heart of the country's
government studying how the country got
to this point provides some important
lessons in the perils of political
monopolies first a quick history lesson
while official racism in South Africa
dates back to colonial times the
particularly brutal system of racial
segregation known as apartheid was
ushered in just after World War 2 Nelson
Mandela was a key leader in the
anti-apartheid struggle he was convicted
on charges of crimes against the state
in the 60s and imprisoned for 27 years
there is no celestial camp counselor to
step in and make things right and
Mandela's life is a testament to the
fact that we can do it on our own when
he assumed the presidency in 1994 he
embedded radically inclusive humanism
into the foundational legal blueprints
of the freshly reborn South Africa South
Africa Constitution has probably the
most thorough going protection of
individual rights of any constitution in
the world it's the project the mind of
the soul have been free political rights
and even exceeds those found in the
United States Constitution the only
country in Africa for example in which
gay marriage is legal
at this point
Mandela's party the African National
Congress has an overwhelming majority in
the South African government in 1999
during the second ever national election
since the fall of apartheid the ANC
takes two-thirds of the National
Assembly and the Secession of the
presidency amounts to an anointment not
an election their facto president of
South Africa already is Tabatha he's
extraordinarily intelligent it really is
quite obscene that poor countries become
net capital exporters to rich countries
extremely well-educated you have to read
you have got to understand you're going
to analyse he has a taste for Scotch so
I'm saying that certain things like this
that are fundamental which i think would
be of general application in other words
a person very far away from the
townships possessing great intelligence
often gives people in power the false
sense that they can master any issue
that comes before them and Inman Becky's
case that hubris mixed with certain
cultural and securities to inform public
policy in the most toxic way imagine
Becky a man with no medical training
raising doubts about whether HIV really
does cause AIDS
I think it would make a religion of
beauty to say well as far as health
policies once and we shall leave that
matter to the doctors and scientists
government refuses to supply
hiv-positive pregnant women drugs which
could save their babies thousands babies
are being sacrificed every year in South
Africa from 63 at the end of apartheid
51 by the time in Bakke he was resigned
as president South African president
Thabo Mbeki's been asked to resign he
interfered in a legal case involving its
rifle because the ANC effectively runs a
political monopoly the party isn't
punished from when becky's gross
failures which means the ANC is free to
elevate to power a man who's even more
reprehensible a guy who'd previously
been removed from office because of
fraud charges related to a five billion
dollar weapons deal he's magnificently
corrupt the government is spending two
hundred and fifty million ranch to
upgrade his own private residence people
have made a lot of hullabaloo government
insisted from the security point of view
they need to participate to the gym the
guest rooms the visitor center the 31
new building do these constitute
security enhancements think I think you
must you must respect me the leaders who
are they are not there to rectify the
mistake of the past they are there to
live cronyism that is present within the
ANC is extraordinary
the ANC read this written as wealth
amongst their leaders only have teachers
the teachers are going government is not
even taking any action until apartheid
struggle icon document 11 fella has said
that the education system today
it's worse than during apartheid she's
right I am not afraid to say she was
right only 30 percent people who take
the high school exit exam get a high
enough score on it to even hope for
admission to unemployment under the ANC
had skyrocketed
Nancy inherited the unemployment rate
about 15 percent
we are talking about 40% 4-0 gulf
between white incomes and black incomes
is greater now than it was in 1990 for
ordinary black South Africans do not see
room for advancement if you do not know
someone who is in the party elite Zuma
has said that he's confident that South
Africans will continue to vote until
Jesus comes the ANC because of its large
electoral majority feels in principle
people are starting to have quite
specific and quite disturbing you dare
to go to the old South Africa than the
new South Africa
we have regressed into every racists
dream deep deep disillusionment with
existing class
so what yourself in the position of a
poor black South Africa you've watched
the epic toppling of apartheid and the
ascension of the transcendent figure of
Nelson Mandela and with it the promise
of a new era 20 years later your
material existence hasn't much improved
at all that beautiful promise has gone
unfulfilled and you're staring down a
government that's dominated by a
political party that is wholly
unresponsive to your needs
people who feel they're voiceless and
excluded
quite extraordinary backlash nage South
African Special 45 violent protests
every day
versatile incredibly angry country
people a barricade in street from
burning stuff an L but corruption birth
defect would have been from it never
happened think about it black South
Africans are now riding against the
party of Nelson Mandela as their
frustration grows they're willing to
turn to anyone who might offer them the
hope of genuine renewal it is a new
political party economic freedom
fighters advise young firebrand Julius
Malema when poking the kitchen for
illusion people really blew them off as
way too far left
what nationalization expropriation of
land without compensation they're really
gaining steam really fast so Bailey too
much my thinking about land without
compensation worked no it doesn't mean
if it doesn't work anywhere it can't
work yet throughout reconciliation let's
throw out the Constitution is to
fundamentally abandon Mandela's legacy
Malcolm X talk about House Negroes you
know House Negroes are black people who
identify with the oppressors and you
speak like a house
grated prinzni delinquent South Africa
the recontact should learn the lessons
of history what went wrong in the rest
of Africa
how do we avoid debt neighbouring
countries had been completely destroyed
by a socialist experiment probably the
two teachers in Barbary the Cask
fighting as the polarization of his
nation of like a method intended
violence and poverty and it like ruined
the lives of million from the influence
and problems except they're not going to
recover for decades ever clearer if my
name is likely to be that way
and the Zimbabwean so far are doing very
good and if we fall into that future
from wherever in the world I will then
find myself I will always be able to say
so the Africans were warned two years in
advance and being a free and open
society like we are today it will be
harsh but true to say so they're
freaking brought this front page upon
themselves and they ended up with the
government they deserve